hey I was gonna braise my oh yes I am
wearing a tank top
have you seen these guns so today we're
gonna focus shop youtubers into their
spirit animals no one asks me to do this
but we're gonna do it anyway um so
somebody boom
man I bet they had a bit better tip that
there she is
she has hamsters right her guinea pigs
there Kenny picks them all right you can
barely see the difference already
that's a good sign okay so let's begin
the morphing
[Music]
and this is some sick [ __ ] spurred
animalistic s' going on alright so
obviously her eyes needs to be
transplanted see I always wish I just
became a plastic surgeon because I
really think I have a knack for these
links alright so you just tell my god
I've you just take the eyes and ya ya
[ __ ] place them on top
[Music]
that looks great so good my god zoella
if you ever need like a plastic surgeon
let me know
let's implant the mouth
[Music]
it's almost like you can't see the
difference oh my god Peter pie making
furry happened since 1984
Jesus Christ you're so goddamn welcome
no one really appreciates is the it pay
pay you just screams no I make art all
right I make all right
do you see this how is this our arty
look at this filter that I'm adding bam
bam a filter I've just added that [ __ ]
filter man before after before after
zoella is a hamster clap your hands
everyone
[Music]
dan is obviously a cat no question about
it oh my god
it's like I almost can't tell a
difference their resemblance Dan should
just quit YouTube and become a cat like
seriously Wow amazing
it would be cheating if we don't bring
it out Dan's beautiful eyes this is why
you should never post high-resolution
pictures of yourself online just a bad
idea wait I mean a good idea obviously
but bad ideas he has that same
grumpiness in his eyes maybe they are
the same person
okay this is kind of scaring me
what the [ __ ] Dan what did you Dan oh
god dad what that dan dan it's pretty
eyes gonna say they're very nice very
nice
and there we go I look so real very
strange now it's not symmetric which is
bothering me you know even people like
dan has not 100% symmetry we'll fix it
don't worry this is why I'm here
yeah that looks legit so sorry dan dan
is not active finita let's look at
before Maris
oh god I'm whatever it's kind of before
there you go beautiful
Janice not again
okay ray will rain William G all right
are dumped what spirit animal is him is
him that's a hedgehog oh my god
hedgehogs are the cutest [ __ ] thing
I've ever seen in my life oh my god
it's like there's no difference oh my
god the ice they're so Hollow
there we go all right all right
watch animal hmm
rhinos of course how could we have been
so blind how could we have been so by
can't believe I missed this resemblance
it's been in front of our eyes breasts
it's been in front of our eyes all along
god damn it I wish I was a rhino too
they just [ __ ] Rhino [ __ ] all day do
i rhino shed all day no I don't I don't
I guess sourest
they're my favorite they're kissing this
is the true fan fiction that we were all
waiting for you can stop watching
YouTube now there won't be any a better
music or videos than this you've seen
you've seen it all now I've seen it all
I see can you tell the quality's
dropping because I'm getting tired
Harry Harry my child what animal are you
what speaks to you that potato the
potato is strong with your Harry never
let go never let go of the potato this
is how the dinosaurs were instinct this
is how Smosh cease to exist wow that
looks battles really [ __ ] disturbing
what the [ __ ] that looks like his actual
skin I have to go my people are calling
me thank you for watching this video
leave a like if you enjoyed and
supporting this channel I don't know why
you would do that that's ridiculous
but here's the brofist for you it's
always stay off suppress
dad looks great Wow why did I spend so
much time on this